[Musique]
on va parler maintenant d'initiatives
qui change tout en matière d'éducation
les sites et éducatives autre manière
d'accompagner les enfants de ces
quartiers l'école de la deuxième chance
et les apps de la réussite
[Musique]
reste on va parler d'éducation de
formation c'est vrai très important
c'est
la base et la place alors on va parler
de la cité éducative avec qu'était la
bouille et puis on va parler des hubs de
la réussite avec vous benjamin skoun
alors yahia vos organisations qui se
préoccupe de cette formation mais aussi
des associations qui font un travail
formidable je pense en particulier une
association qui s'appelle la l'afrique
fraternité pour l'égalité des chances
qu'a créé amina satouri amina satory
elle est mère de trois enfants qu'elle
élevait seule l ebit dans ce quartier
quel quartier de delanoë et elle a créé
une association qui regroupe aujourd'hui
plus de 70 enfants alors il ya plusieurs
activités évidemment le soutien scolaire
et mais aussi le sport et la voilà une
idée formidable c'est que de dire mais
il peut faire du sport mais peuvent
faire d'autres sports que ce qu'on leur
propose d'habitude c'est aller faire du
golfe allaient faire du cheval et c'est
ce qu'elle a lancé c'est cette
formidable petite association qui
s'appelle l'afrique d'amina satory on
était voir comment se passe ça se
passait avec justement deux jeunes
golfeurs
green caddie club ces mots n'ont plus de
secrets pour daoud et mohamed une fois
par semaine depuis plus de trois ans ces
deux garçons de 16 ans se rendent au
club de golf de villennes sur seine pour
apprendre la discipline j'adore le golfe
surtout le practice et
toute la semaine j'y pense quand j'en
fais encore j'en fais pas quand tu tape
la balle au practice ça détend coach est
là haut tu crois tu vois la balle partir
loin
après même le jeu sur le parcours ça me
plaît
ah ouais elle est belle celle là
130 cent vingt 120 les sports qui sont
connus sur le quartier on va pas se
mentir c'est plus voilà le
foot la boxe tout du bus c'était très
très difficile de le faire accepter sur
le quartier parce qu'il n'était pas
qu'une eau connu ces puces pour les pour
les gens aisés pour les gens qui sont en
lice une chance qui leur a été donné par
l'association freq qui allie sport et
aide à la scolarité elle est accompagnée
par la fondation green house qui permet
aux enfants défavorisés de pouvoir
accéder à des activités extrascolaires
se couchant et après moi vu qu'on ait
beaucoup chez moi on n'aurait pas à ma
mère elle aurait fait payer faire un
sport pour moi cher et d'espoir pour les
autres mais comment afp du golfe comme
ça et manger sain sport cher maugis mais
j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir un mine a du coup que grâce à
cette occasion j'ai pu en faire
puissance je serais pas là et je tiens à
les en remercier venir aussi aux jouer
au golf c'est aussi
l'accompagnement à ce sport
être respectueux travail et la rigueur
on tient pas ouais bah je la sens
parce que corps je la sens pas la balle
c'est un qui sait trop bien on le voit
avec ce nouvel maintenant les golfeurs
qu'on a c'est de ne pas leur fermer les
portes il faut qu'ils essayent ce sport
et qui soit ouvert pour eux c'est vrai
que sans la formation les parents ne
pourront pas payer la totalité de ce
sport avec comme exemple les célèbres
bobby jones tiger woods ou encore
qu'albert tchaï daoud et mohamed ne
compte pas s'arrêter là jerry d'être pro
et si possible au dessus c'est d'aller
le plus haut possible peut-être devenir
un jour c'est une fierté d'avoir deux
d'avoir mettre des jeunes qui sont là
depuis trois ans et demi dans le golfe
et et les accompagner si une fierté pour
nous une quinzaine d'enfants sont aidés
par l'association sur la discipline du
golfe l'association ferait qu envisage
d'organiser plus de court par la suite
pour que les enfants puissent passer
leurs drapeaux équivalent du flocon pour
le ski et participer à des compétitions
dans les yvelines donc on va parler de
d'éducation de formation catella bouille
vous êtes la chef de projet de la cité
éducative alors là on est à l'espace
borloo dans la cité de la noé hills elle
sera dans quelques temps tout près d'ici
dans une école alors l'alcool oui la
cité éducative simone veil sera implanté
effectivement dans loin d'ici à là en
lieu et place actuellement de l'école
dans genèse l'espace victor hugo avec
aussi le collège casas en partie rénové
et benjamin lecomte bonjour bonjour vous
êtes conseiller régional d'île de france
et vous êtes le président des meubles de
la réussite alors faudra qu'on précise
que célèbre de la réussite c'est un peu
un nom générique qui regroupe à la fois
l'école de la deuxième chance et aussi
ce qu'on appelle les smart universités
ce qui nous permet de te faire venir les
enseignements de l'université ici plutôt
que les étions d'état se déplacer quand
ya pas de vivacité à côté de leur lit
aux habitants c'est ça c'est ça on peut
conclure de la réussite c'est un
écosystème autour de plusieurs métiers
et dans cet écosystème il ya plusieurs
dispositifs dont des écoles deuxième
chance donc dans les yvelines en seine
et marne dans le val d'oise et des
partenaires cités ce sont des
tiraillements supérieur ont fait venir
l'université dans le territoire et nous
on part d'un principe c'est que dans nos
territoires soir dans un quartier
prioritaire de la ville soit la réalité
il ya des talents qui s'ignorent qui
sont passés au travers du système
éducatif parce que pour plein de raisons
de parcours de vie qui n'ont pas trouvé
leur voie et nous notre métier en fin de
compte c'est de faire éclore et clore
ses talents et c'est ça qui c'est le
métier de la réussite et on en attend là
dedans et c'est la preuve qu'il y a des
talents dans un quartier rien à bosser
c'est une richesse bien plus ses
ressources comme on dit qu'ils sont dans
les quartiers c'est nos ressources
humaines qui pour le pays sont mal
exploitées si on peut utiliser ce terme
là et qui serait une qui sont une
richesse formidable pour nous pour notre
nation alors on va parler de la cité
éducative on est allé vous voir il y
avait une réunion avec lui il ya eu qui
est la déléguée du préfet et karine
bouchard akela mon principal du collège
rené cassin c'était un matin vous étiez
là on regarde et puis on en reparle tout
de suite après
dispositif lancé en juillet 2018 les
sites et éducatives ont pour objectif
d'intensifier la prise en charge des
enfants de leur naissance à leurs 25 ans
situé dans le nord des yvelines
chanteloup-les-vignes fait partie des 80
ville lauréate du label cité éducative
décernée par l'état le but suivre les
jeunes chantelouve et et chante l'ouvèze
à travers tout leur parcours scolaire
mais aussi les ouvrir aux nombreuses
opportunités qui s'offrent à eux et pour
mettre en place ce projet trois co
pilote lydia uc délégué du préfet en
charge de la ville de champeaux les
vignes pour représenter l'état ça va
apporter aussi aux acteurs de ce
territoire une façon différente de
travail elle karine bouchard un
principal du collège rené cassin à
chanteloup les vignes pour représenter
l'éducation nationale nous confrontons
les solutions que nous avions déjà et
nous les enrichissant et qu'at-il à
mouiller adjointe en charge de la
jeunesse et de l'éducation à la mairie
de chanteloup les vignes pour
représenter la ville tout on est
impliqué dans cette dynamique éducative
ses trois co pilote ont pour objectif
commun de créer des conditions
éducatives optimale pour les jeunes
chantelouve et pourrait parvenir elle
doit faire travailler ensemble tous les
acteurs qui participent à l'éducation et
l'épanouissement de l'enfant l'idée
c'est de réunir tous les acteurs que ce
soit la ville l'éducation nationale les
associations les parents pour faire
alliance autour d'un projet pour les
enfants et les jeunes d'un territoire
c'est l'esprit même de la cité éducative
le fait de rassembler autour de l'enfant
les différents acteurs sur les
différents temps de l'enfant et avec une
cohérence et la même volonté de faire
réussir la cité éducative bénéficie
principalement aux habitants du quartier
de la noé qui représente plus de la
moitié de la population de
chanteloup-les-vignes ce quartier
connaît un taux de pauvreté de 37% ces
deux fois supérieur à la moyenne
nationale et seulement 57% des 16 25 ans
sont scolarisés
la plupart des disciplines font appel à
la lecture et on voit à quel point c'est
un frein parce que c'est quelque chose
qu'on travaille en collaboration avec le
premier degré et sur le second degré et
on voit que ces sources
vraiment de décrochage de
voilà d'un certain nombre d'élèves parce
que l'accès à la lecture et à la langue
française beaucoup de nos élèves ne
parlent pas forcément le français
à la maison pour faire face à ces
difficultés la cité éducative a permis
de créer des postes inédits comme celui
de référence suivi parcours lycéens pour
accompagner les jeunes de chanteloup
après le collège on n'a pas de blessés à
chanteloup les vignes mais l art est
repéré 27 laisser différence sur
lesquels soit répartie nos jeunes une
fois au lit donc c'est quand même assez
important avec des risques de décrochage
scolaire est donc là tout le travail
tout le savoir faire de notre
professionnel
c'est précisément d'accompagner les
enfants les jeunes sur les difficultés
ce projet de cité éducative s'inscrit
également dans un plan local
d'urbanisation sont complémentaires avec
un gros projet de rénovation urbaine qui
va s'appeler la cité simone veil en
coeur de quartier cette nouvelle cité
verra le jour en 2024 2025 et sera
entièrement dévoué à l'éducation et à la
culture
elle comprendra notamment la démolition
et la rénovation d'une école maternelle
primaire mais aussi d'un collège on va
déjà voir effectivement la destruction
de l'école dorgelès les enfants de
l'école dorgelès vont être accueillis
dans une cité qui est en train de se
construire la cité champeau qui un
accueil temporaire pour les élèves du
premier degré le projet prévoit aussi la
construction d'une médiathèque et d'une
ludothèque l'intérêt d'une médiathèque
une lune les deux textes c'est vraiment
la possibilité pour les jeunes du
territoire d'avoir accès aux livres à la
culture cinématographique que voilà aux
jeux de société
avons tous vu et ce qui est intéressant
dans ce type de structure assez le côté
familial ce nouveau quartier devrait
également accueillir une maison des
parents un espace multimédia et
plusieurs pôles santé formation ambition
réussite citoyenneté pour réussir à
coordonner tout ça les trois co pilote
et les acteurs du territoire se
réunissent pour travailler autour de
quatre axes la cité éducative elle
s'articule autour de quatre axes lac sur
la parentalité un axe sur le bien-être
la santé un axe sur la communication le
langage l'accès au numérique et puis un
dernier axe sur va réussir réussir
s'ouvrir au monde donc les actions elles
sont réparties par axe l'idée c'est de
les découvrir il y en a beaucoup qui
sont renouvelés par rapport à l'année
dernière chacune des propositions et
retranscrite sur une fiche détaillée en
fonction de l'objectif visé du public
visé des résultats attendus et du budget
alloué puisqu'il sera organisé sur ses
fiches
d'asseoir sa décision
d'action la cité éducative de chanteloup
comprend 28 porteurs d'actions il s'agit
d'associations de parents d'institutions
qui souhaitent apporter leurs idées
hélas ce matin on est en comité
technique avec différents
interlocuteurs pour
étudier les différentes demandes voir si
ça correspond aux critères
échanger les uns et les autres sur des
réorientations
des points forts mais encore à
travailler la transversalité du
partenariat construit voilà pour ses
tubes jobs c'est d'abord une réunion de
pré arbitrage on va dire pour construire
la programmation 2022 de la cité ducati
au total le budget de la cité éducative
représente un peu plus d'un million
d'euros répartis sur trois ans les
financements seront assurés jusqu'en
la cité éducative et justement aînés du
plan borloo
la première a été
expérimentée à grigny justement est la
particularité de chant tout c'est quand
même
le projet urbain au service du sud du
projet éducatif en fait c'est le projet
éducatif qui préfigure le projet urbain
qui lui même est au service de la
réussite du projet éducatif
ce ceux qui commencent sont les acteurs
éducatifs
de la ville est en fête oui la ville
travaille depuis 2016 à un projet de
rénovation urbaine en coeur de quartier
qui regroupe une école un accueil de
loisirs et pour l'ado et un collège avec
l'idée de reconstruire et de créer
l'école de demain avec une ambition
autour de la continuité éducative de la
coopération entre les acteurs éducatifs
travailler sur les atouts aussi des
élèves qui sont les landes les arts la
culture travailler sur le numérique et
l'inclusion numérique et faire une cité
rayonnante c'est à dire ouverte sur le
quartier ont il s'agit pas de construire
une école avec quatre murs et un toit
mais vient vraiment l'école de demain
avec des fonctions nouvelles comme une
bibliothèque une ludothèque une maison
des familles un pôle santé un espace
multimédia etc c'est à dire des
fonctions qui seront toujours le même
établissement danse en fait c'est un peu
conçu comme un campus
éducatif
c'est à dire qu'il est prévu que ça
puisse ouvrir en dehors du temps
scolaire sur le quartier les autres
écoles les autres les autres les deux
collèges mais aussi sur les habitants
hors temps scolaire pour que ça puisse
être accessible à tous et que ce soient
des lieux ressources
culturels éducatifs
de loisirs numériques et s'est ouvert à
l'ensemble de la ville et la conception
ça a été fait en unisson tout le monde
alors oui on a travaillé dès le début
c'était vraiment là une volonté très
forte de notre maire de travailler avec
l'ensemble des acteurs éducatifs sur une
concertation donc on a
construit un projet éducatif avec des
grands principes comme la coopération
entre les acteurs le bien-être de tous
avec des espaces verts est une cité
rayonnante de l'adaptabilité donc avec
la conception de bâtiments
modulables et adaptables et puis aussi
l'ouverture sur le monde l'ouverture sur
l'extérieur pas seulement le reste de la
ville mais aussi
le monde c'est une manière en fait d'eux
des sanctuary zélés l'école au fait
alors que beaucoup de monde depuis très
longtemps alors oui on c'est une
conception nouvelle de l'éducation en
fait on fait éducation ensemble et grâce
à ce projet innovant on a obtenu la
ville de chanteloup a été une des
premières à obtenir le label cité
éducative en septembre 2010 est donc
vous n'aurez 2010 9,1 su aussi du plan
borloo issus de tout le travail de la
ville autour de la politique éducative
puisque là c'est quand même particulier
qu'une ville se saisissent à ce point là
d'une politique éducatif donc c'est une
conception nouvelle de l'éducation dans
le sens où ces trois pilotes sarsat pour
sa pause ça se pose sur la politique
éducative de la ville de l'éducation
nationale et de l'état donc on est trois
co pilote comme vous le disiez le début
patrice sur sept sites éducative et on
construit
autour de quatre axes sur la parentalité
la coopération le bien-être et le
travail
intercatégorielle on va dire le travail
en coopération
sur la partie langage langues cultures
et numériques mais aussi ouvrir les
jeunes ouvert le champ des possibles
c'est dans les grands objectifs de
l'état sur les sites éducatifs
montrer aux jeunes qu'ils peuvent avoir
de l'ambition leur donner des repères
leur donner un réseau pour qu'il puisse
aller plus loin dans leur dans leurs
ambitions et puis on est là pour
construire le parcours éducatif des
enfants et des jeunes de 0 à 25 ans fait
ma mission c'est une expérience qui est
né de la propre imagination de notre
propre imagination française où il ya
des exemples à l'étranger qui qui
ressemblaient à celles qui ont marché
alors justement la cité éducative c'est
justement la possibilité de faire de
l'innovation éducative et
d'expérimentation donc bien évidemment
on travaille avec l'éducation nationale
les associations s'étaient
vus les parents surtout au niveau des
acteurs éducatifs les parents sont
essentiels
donc on travaille à des expérimentations
nouvelles on met en place par exemple
des espaces snow hélène sur la gestion
des émotions pour les enfants etc on
travaille sur les neurosciences de
classe qui a très intéressant c'est que
l'éducation nationale elle même et dans
cette ex volonté d'expérimentation est
donc là on construit une culture
éducatif commune chacun ne reste pas sur
sa culture institutionnelle on va dire
est professionnel on construit une
culture commune c'est vraiment un des
enjeux forts de cette cité ducale iv de
ces sites éducatifs fisc y en a quand
même un certain nombre en france a fait
école pour le cas est ce qu'il ya des
passerelles qui sont prévues justement
entre les différentes structures sachant
que aujourd'hui c'est on a quand même la
question de l'enfermement
souvent les gens tout est fait pour que
les gens restent dans leur environnement
et n'en sortent pas et comment à travers
un projet comme ça il pourrait on
pourrait pousser les jeunes justement à
sortir de leur environnement à les voir
autre chose alors justement au lieu de
travailler comme ça en silo les
formations interprofessionnelle déjà
nous apprennent et nous permettent de
travailler tous ensemble les acteurs de
l'éducation on a un axe très fort au
niveau de notre site éducatif c'est la
réussite
et les parcours éducatif des jeunes de
16 à 25 ans et là on a une charge et
d'éducation enfin chargé de parcours
éducatif des lycéens puisqu'on n'a pas
de lycée à chanteloup donc ça a permis
d'étendre le territoire éducatif de la
ville à 27 lycées différents vous rendez
compte sur lesquelles sont réparties nos
jeunes de la seconde à la terminale donc
ça nous on a déjà étendu notre
territoire éducatif au delà de la ville
et en plus on s'en donne une vraie
attractivité à ce territoire on
travaille avec l'essec le centre égalité
des chances
avec sur une pourquoi pas pour
l'excellence il ya une grande école
pourquoi pas moi tout un programme et
trouve sa voix aussi sur l'orientation
pour pour donner de l'ambition aux
jeunes leur faire qu'on travaille aussi
sur l'estimé de soi sur l'ouverture
culturelle sur les ans à l'oral enfin
voilà toutes ses dimensions là qui sont
essentiels à la fois dans l'éducation
dans le monde du travail dans la forme
et dans la formation et que ce que
disaient aussi pour le monde du travail
j'ai une question
c'est où vous une révolution dans la
manière de concevoir l'éducation mais
comme le sont les écoles de la deuxième
chose sous les ors de la réussite est-ce
que c'est facile à apporter parce qu'il
ya pas de résistance il ya des gens qui
vous disent en attendre et de l'école
c'est fait pour donner un enseignement
qui soit le même partout et et on change
rien quoi quel que soit le lieu il ya
beaucoup on entend beaucoup ça des
enseignants qui peuvent dire le travail
et des parents c'est pas facile ou avec
est-ce que des résistances ou est ce que
finalement balaie les résultats que vous
obtenez finissent par vaincre ces
résistances alors on a vraiment l'appui
au niveau national de l'éducation
nationale qui est des résistances dans
de toutes parts une services de la ville
voilà
là là c'est vraiment l'idée c'est
vraiment de travailler tous ensemble et
on a des équipes qui sont là depuis
longtemps on a très peu de turnover sur
la ville de chanteloup on a des gens
impliqués l'éducation nationale fait
déjà un travail exceptionnel avec en
plus tout le réseau d'éducation
prioritaire déjà habitués à ce travail
transversal
donc en fait on a il faut avoir un maire
qui a une vraie vision pour sa ville une
équipe municipale qui a une vraie vision
et qui est ça s'appuie aussi sur cette
même dynamique éducation nationale est
un
must peut-être
est-ce que vous êtes au caire aussi
d'une expérience j'ai aussi une vente si
tout était parfait on n'existerait pas
simplement
les jeunes qui viennent dans les écoles
même chance à l'as partenaires cités ou
ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui avec la ville
sur le le le les cours du soir et le
soutien scolaire ont fait ça aussi parce
que le ciem d'éducation et c'est un
système de masse qui gère la masse et
nous on gère des individus qui ont des
parcours de vie qu'ont-ils difficulté et
on les gère individuellement c'est la
particularité des dispositifs diable de
la réussite c'est qu'on a des parcours
individualisés
est souvent le premier acte de ce
parcours ce que vous dites est à l'heure
c'est estime de soi c'est à dire tu es
capable de ne
pas tuer en échec tu appelles ton brevet
tard doublé tuait un décrocheur donc les
aspects négatifs que parfois renvoi
l'éducation nationale parce que si ça me
fait comme ça mais c'est vrai que le
système de masse et que ben
il ya eu l'échec c'est parce que les non
c'est vrai pas de quoi faire contre quoi
faire enfin je laisse partenaires cités
j'allais dire elles se remplissent
grasset à kozani sont deux parcours sup
des jeunes qui sont exclues par par
coursier qui a un bts qui a envie de
faire un bts dans les yvelines et dans
la rue alors dit ben non pas possible le
peuple-classe ton dossier pas c'est bon
tu rentreras pas mais qui ont envie de
faire leur bts il arrive chez nous nous
les gros des cohortes arrive après les
voeux ambitions de post bac parce que
ben ils ont pas de choix alors
déjà de trouver de trouver un début de
solution c'est déjà résoudre le problème
c'est dire qu'il ya un problème c'est
pas très grave qui est un problème à
faire rien n'est parfait dans la vie et
je vous rejoins si le up s'est implanté
dans le champ clou c'est que un jour le
maire de chanteloup est venu me voir à
argenteuil pour travailler sur
l'économie change dans les yvelines et
l'implantation à chanteloup et on peut
on ne peut rien faire si apple a volé la
volonté politique d'une commune d'une
agglomération d'un département parce que
c'est tous les acteurs ça négocie
achètent nos services un des jeunes leur
pour citer jean louis borloo qui disait
souvent c'est tout un village qui éduque
un enfant
c'est tout le monde qu'il fait tout le
monde à son niveau cette voie qui
devrait en afrique et toute la ville
dont les faire réussir la vie pour le
faire réussir voir je suis un bébé
borloo gg ge devrait à ses côtés pendant
quelques années donc c'est pour ça aussi
que je me suis retrouvé dans l'est dans
ces écoles là et dans ces dispositifs la
met
oui rien n'est parfait samedi
l'essentiel résout pas tous les
problèmes et c'est pas grave ce qui est
grave ce serait de dire c'est tant pis
on laisse dans l'échec non il ya là j'ai
à dire la bienveillance de la république
à trouver des systèmes parallèles pour
pouvoir les accompagner c'est ça qui est
important
tout à l'heure vous parliez justement de
là il ya quelque chose qui va marquer
vous parlez de rendre les enfants aussi
auteur de la production de la
connaissance
ça me rappelle d'ailleurs une méthode
montessori et la méthode freinet
est ce que à terme
l'éducation nationale doit sortir
justement de deux de ces règles les
habituels pourra pour arriver à ça
alors on est justement quand on parle
d'expérimentation
éducative c'est vraiment main dans la
main avec l'éducation nationale ronald
d'un groupe thématique par exemple de
réflexion sur le travail personnel de
l'élève avec quatre sous-groupes donc là
c'est complètement intercatégorielle
avec des parents aussi qui sont
impliqués et on a la chance d'avoir des
principal de collège et l'inspectrice
aussi éducation nationale complètement
impliqué dans cette innovation
pédagogique là pour le coup
avec du mobilier innovants on a par
exemple des des collèges équipés en pour
les enfants en euros atypique avec des
tables en hauteur et un vélo vous voyez
un pédalier pour permettre de décharger
l'énergie
on travaille comme par balle et dans le
cadre de la cité
mais à des
enfants qu'après mais en marchant par
exemple voilà alors qu'on leur demande
de rester assis donc on est on est on va
prendre vraiment le pari de cette
expérimentation là et dans le cadre du
grand chantier cité simone veil il se
trouve que pendant deux ans le temps du
chantier l'état a déjà commencé voilà
c'est déjà le dans la sillage et donc la
cité champeau c'est un lieu d'incubateur
de projet qui va permettre dit de lancer
des innovations exemple vous fait des
expérimentations l'expérimentation mais
sans pour autant car faut vraiment aller
dans le sens aller dans le menu complet
non non ça c'est ça avec toujours
toujours le respect de principes et puis
surtout de l'enfant et de la rue pour la
réussite de l'enfant un exemple
d'expérimentation par exemple à la
demande des parents la création d'un
pédibus réussir à vous voyez on est
vraiment sur un autre champ que ce
bouquet le rôle de baroque au bout ils
sont dans l'eau ce projet ces
intervenants ils ont alors il serait je
voudrais que mon fils ou ma fille fasse
ça où ils sont plus collectif alors il
il aimerait bien que les enfants
réussissent ils ont peur que ce soit un
dispositif de plus or c'est vraiment une
nouvelle façon de penser l'éducation ils
veulent pas qu'on se serve de leurs
enfants pour faire de l'expérimentation
mode cobayes c'est pas c'est pas ça non
plus donc on les associe complètement et
ils sont très impliqués dans la réussite
de leurs enfants vraiment dans la dans
la après il faut qu'on les conforte
aussi dans leur rôle de parents c'est un
c'est un travail de confiance et qu'ils
comprennent peu différente des
enseignants le droit d'un
travail avec le centre social on se rend
compte et donc les pas beaucoup de
parents que des quelques fois ils
n'osent pas poser des questions aux
enseignants parce que ils ont
l'impression que c'est un manque de
confiance or là on les confond alors on
travaille beaucoup avec eux par exemple
on va créer un film
qu'on va traduire en plusieurs langues
sur être enfant à chanteloup de petits
jusqu'à 25 ans qu'elles sont quelques de
ce territoire rapporte associations
services de la ville le département
également
pour pour les parents pour pour les
enfants et donc est traduit en plusieurs
langues donc là on a pris en compte
cette dimension vraiment grande
interculturalité et de moi je pense
comme une richesse de ce territoire
voilà et c'est les habitants eux mêmes
et les professionnels qui vont alors non
pas traduire parce qu'on a un
interprétariat mais qui vont dire qu'ils
vont qui vont ils vont avoir leur voix
enregistrée sur le film donc on a
vraiment une participation active des
parents et en plus l'origine de ce
projet c'est donc on a lancé un appel à
initiatives éducatives tous acteurs de
l'éducation pour que les parents
puissent les parents les jeunes les
professionnels faire proposer des
innovations éducatives qui sont validées
par un jury on a fait ça de façon très
rigoureuse et très sérieuse avec un
grand respect et donc cette ce projet a
été
validé non là on a l'impression d'être
sur une autre planète au fait on n'est
pas sur la planète france non non on est
champion c'est ça justement on est on
est ravi d'être là parce que ça permet
de mettre en lumière tout ça et des
belges initiative et cette idée
justement parce qu'on tente pendant très
longtemps on a reproché aux eaux à
l'école d'être fermé et on a des aussi
beaucoup se sont déchargées sur l'école
en disant que c'était à l'école
d'éduquer les enfants et tout ce travail
permet justement d'associer les parents
à l'éducation
alors est ce qu'il faudrait pas d'après
vous faire ce travail que certains
demandent depuis un certain temps c'est
à dire de changer le nom de l'éducation
nationale et de l'appeler désormais
l'instruction nationale
ça s'appelait l'instruction publique
est-ce qu'il faut pas revenir à ça parce
que le canton vie éducation nationale
les gens pensent que c'est l'éducation
alors faut pas juste s'arrêter à une
appellation
que ça descend sur les gens appelant sa
cité éducative
non mais vraiment vraiment on est dans
l'alliance éduqué je vous rejoins
complètement sur comment penser
autrement on est dedans et
les enseignants eux mêmes ont déjà
beaucoup évolué dans leur façon de de
concevoir
leur métier et leur rôle
il ya des cafés des parents qui
fleurissent dans les écoles il ya ouvrir
l'école aux parents pour la réussite des
enfants c'est un dispositif éducation
nationale pour permettre aux parents
allophones primoarrivants de mieux
maîtriser le français donc il ya déjà
beaucoup de
d'ouverture et dans les réseaux
d'éducation prioritaire il ya des il ya
des parcours comme le parcours santé le
parcours citoyenneté le parcours il ya
des ya déjà des choses
sa facilité beaucoup le travail et les
missions de l'est qui sont les miennes
mais l'émission l'action de la ville
haut niveau alors je présente un super
idéal parce que c'est oui bien sûr
les difficultés des reçus chez des rats
la mesure du parking mais on y croit un
truc qui change un peu et c'est vrai
aussi pour les hommes de la réussite
c'est à dire que
vous le regardez comment veut mettre fin
dans les quartiers dits de la politique
de la ville généralement les écoles
qu'on avait c'était quand même pas les
meilleures j'ai dit jeudi au téléphone
europe et vous avez aimé mais
mais là on est en train de changer de
perspective parce qu'on a l'impression
que c'est l'excellence qui vient non
dans ces quartiers d'ailleurs eu
d'ailleurs peut-être bien si ça marche
toujours pas pourquoi s'adresserait dans
le quartier de la 1000e des sites
éducatifs pourquoi ils n'auraient pas
dans le 16e arrondissement non mais j'ai
dit oui il renvoie l'arrière
tout à fait à ceci près que comme les
écoles de la deuxième chance non les
écoles chance ça concerne pas que
moi je tairai les noms de mai s'est
mariée que des enfants de grands patrons
parlementaires etc m'appelle pour me
dire mon enfant à décrocher j'arrive
plus à le remettre dans le système
d'éducation c'est parce qu'il veut faire
il sent pas bien à l'école est-ce qui
peut venir chez toi en haut de ces pour
qu'on puisse avoir un parcours
d'insertion avec lui parce que on sent
qu'il veut travailler mais sait pas où
mais il veut travailler nous avons eu de
la réussite on veut pas l'insertion
sociale ont fait l'insertion économique
notre but c'est d'en parler aux jeunes
puissent s'insérer économiquement parce
que pour nous la réussite enfin compte
aussi par le travail
non je crois qu'on en reparle dans
quelques instants non mais c'est vrai
que d'une certaine façon c'est
l'excellence qui inquiète qu'il a quoi
oui oui oui peut-être que l'innovation
au centre et à l'est oui la ressource
humaine et la ressource humaine et puis
on essaie des choses banales apolline
volonté politique et ça c'est
fondamental et vous disiez ça pourrait
exister dans le 16ème mois à ceci près
que nos jeunes ici manque quand même de
réseaux manque de perspective si on les
accompagne pas si on leur montre pas ne
serait-ce que la diversité des métiers
qui existent sachant que les métiers de
demain n'existe pas encore donc on
construit aussi avec eux le monde de
demain et donc
on est aussi en train de rééquilibrer
des inégalités de territoire aussi sur
des villes en quartiers de la ville
quand je dis je veux dire ça pourra être
aussi parce que par ses expérimentations
une piste pour l'éducation nationale
d'une façon générale
on a déjà rencontré en fin de rencontre
à plusieurs reprises le dden donc le
directeur d'académie service éducation
nationale qui a été très intéressé par
justement l'expérimentation le fait
qu'on construise pour maintenant l'école
de demain on va dire avec cette
dimension est là on revient sur la
partie cité simone veil
d2 que l'évolution des besoins c'est à
dire que pour dans 30 ans
les besoins seront encore évoluer et
donc la conception même on revient au
projet architectural conception même des
débats team débattent du bâtiment c'est
que ce soit en plateau modulable voilà
dans cette dimension là
le cabinet d'architectes voilà travaille
dessus et on a avec le cabinet
indivisible qui est un cabinet à
distance à maîtrise d'ouvragé qui nous a
accompagnés dans toute la démarche de
concertation avec les habitants les
parents les professionnels
on a créé un plan des usages voilà plan
des usages des différentes fonctions
voilà et à la phase qu on y attend ce
qu'on veut il et puis comme on veut
travailler ensemble on va parler des
hubs delà de la réussite auparavant nous
disait il ya aussi des associations qui
s'occupent de de ses talents parce que
livre de la réussite ça repose sur
l'idée qu'il ya beaucoup de talent dans
ces quartiers et je peux vous de voir le
portrait de joachim löw joachim c'est un
stage garçon qui était tellement émotif
que
le des médecins médias c'est à sa mère
il faut il faut le mettre dans un
hôpital psychiatrique et aux rues de le
mettre dans un hôpital psychiatrique
elle l'a inscrite dans cette compagnie
que vous connaissez bien qu avait
invoqué la compagnie des contraires qui
a été créée par noah tomasi une
trentaine d'années qu'est la voix cirque
une école de théâtre et et joachim il
est devenu la vedette d'un film qui
était consacrée à cette compagnie des
contraire ce film s'appelle de repères
des contraires et les deux de l'oea
rinaldi il était présenté au festival de
cannes l'année dernière et je vous
propose de voir le portrait de joachim
est donnée de sa maman d'ailleurs c'est
un portrait signé beach et et meriem
santesteban
[Musique]
à côté
aujourd'hui une passion le théâtre était
au début un échappatoire pour joachim
enfants il avait des difficultés à gérer
ses émotions j'allais au théâtre et
vraiment trouvé un truc super quoi de
permettre de
jouer un rôle
d'exprimer des émotions et puis s'était
installé clac quoi et puis d'un seul
coup il était valorisé aussi il était
mis en lumière alors que jusqu alors
les instituteurs c'est plutôt comment
faire avec lui quand j'étais un enfant
qui était tellement dévoré par ses
émotions qu'il était incapable de
produire quoi que ce soit à l'écrit
c'était des crises de larmes sous sa
chaise des fois j'étais obligé de venir
le chercher le calme et à la maison
il y avait toute une prise en charge
aussi par un psychologue si c'était très
compliqué je comprends qu'à l'école
c'était pour les profs aussi très très
compliqué mais c'est ça ça lui a permis
de ça le théâtre de pouvoir s'exprimer
[Musique]
il a vécu aussi du harcèlement forcément
quand on entre une différence et c'est
ça qui est formidable c'est ce qu'il a
pu dire aussi c'est que un moment donné
tu avais exprimé un truc comme ça
l'année prof tu avais dit mais comment
quand les autres rigolent de toi comment
ça ne touche pas et tu as dis ouais je
mens mêmes barrières comme marocain
c'est mental quoi il dit et ça j'ai vu
que c'était ça le théâtre aussi c'est ça
commence à head où je les ai déjà vus
jouer au chapiteau ou sari dont là parce
que des fois ya les centres de loisirs
ça rigole et tout mais malgré tout faut
dire son texte ou tout de suite tout ça
et c'est ce qui l'a aidé
joakim prend souvent visite à son
professeur et aux enfants de la
compagnie des contraires comme il a
appris la pratique théâtrale sous ce
chapiteau à chanteloup-les-vignes plus
du théâtre gerald où j'ai des facilités
à apprendre le texte est et après qu'on
a le texte il ya donc par exemple la sat
qui est mon professeur de théâtre
qui m'apprend le
comment comment je vais jouer ce texte
qu'elle pose aussi parce que par exemple
un silence c'est vraiment le dans la
seine et c'est ce qu'il faut intégrer
dans la seine pour c'est un peu comme la
musique faut que ce soit vraiment tout
harmonieux et ça permet vraiment de
faire un
belle pièce on a estimé depuis l'année
dernière que il est prêt pour poursuivre
le travail tout seul maintenant qu'elle
est au décès dont qu'il aimerait bien
faire un bac 4 et est allé plus loin
pourquoi pas faire des études
supérieures et devenir comédien des
enseignements de la sade qui servent au
quotidien aux jeunes acteurs maintenant
ça se passe très bien
première fois jacques laisné
encouragements sur mon bulletin c1 et
pillages je progresse et puis bien sûr
le comportement
il est beaucoup mieux quoi ne serait ce
que pour ton brevet il avait une chose
alors à la présenter il l'a fait devant
moi il reste debout judy venons tu dois
te soit mais dit non moi j'ai appris
comme ça parce que l'ancrage il est
comme ça si je reste debout monte je
vais dire autrement et effectivement au
final d'une bonne note pour l'oral
[Musique]
m
en prime
d'une pièce de théâtre de monsieur
moi d'ailleurs je peux en faire mais ce
que bon me semble ne serais-tu points un
homme à les faire courir le bruit que
j'ai chez moi de l'apprendre cacher
[Musique]
créé en 1991 par nez aux à une femme
tout juste arrivé du brésil la compagnie
des contraire est une association de
chanteloup-les-vignes sa vocation
travailler sur l'inclusion et
l'insertion par l'art c'est bien sûr le
cas de joachim un jour il arrivé ici
j'ai compris tout de suite que joaquin
et les il avait une sensibilité et
spéciale était le théâtre pourrait être
pour lui vraiment le chemin de la
lumière il tenait toujours le rôle
principal à l'heure d'été bramois ont il
est toujours en moteur de toute la
troupe de théâtre qui s'appelle
sentinelles des contraires il a évolué
beaucoup joaquín le continue à évoluer
j'étais très très compliqué pour moi de
gérer cette situation
et en même temps la première fois que je
les ai vus jouer au théâtre
c'est à dire qu'on vous fait voir une
autre facette aussi de votre enfant est
ce qu'il est capable de faire c'est pas
uniquement ce que vous renvoie à l'école
d'un enfant compliqué qu'il n'a pas sa
place ici enfin c'était c'était violent
mais nous à elle n'a rien voulu savoir
de mon histoire personnelle de son
histoire personnelle elle a pris comme
ça et elle a sorti ce qui était bon de
lui alors vraiment on peut dire que
merci quoi elle me pousse vers le haut
toujours mais elle pousse pas que moi
mais vraiment tout le monde et elle
cherche le meilleur d'eux
de tout coincé avec une rigueur
attention - ont fait pas n'importe quoi
c'est parce que derrière il ya aussi
toute une démarche éducative et quand on
le questionne à propos de son avenir un
peu compliqué parce que je ne suis pas
devin mais bon moi ce que j'aimerais
c'est ce que j'aimerais faire c'est
c'est vraiment comédien après il ya un
comédien on peut il ya plein de choses
qu'on peut faire il ya on peut passer à
la radio va passer à la télé
être acteur dans les cinémas dans le
théâtre et moi serait plus là pour
l'instant de théâtre et je veux voir si
toutes choses qui me plaisent les
doubleurs aussi il ya plein de choses
joachim joue également le premier rôle
du film documentaire sur la compagnie
intitulé le repère des contraire de
l'oea rinaldi un rôle comme un symbole
pour lui qui a fait du chapiteau son
repère même si à 15 ans aujourd'hui la
compagnie ne fait plus partie de son
quotidien
[Musique]
on va parler de
la réussite élèves de la réussite il
faut dire qu'on l'a dit un petit peu
pour le rappeler c'est à la fois l'école
de la deuxième chance et c'est à la fois
les smart universités alors leur site
c'est comme vous l'a dit c'est un
écosystème donc on a plusieurs métiers
s'est révélé fort mais accéléré on part
du principe que dans nos quartiers dans
la réalité il ya des talents qu'on est
là pour faire éclore ces talents et si
vous reprendre
une métaphore qu'on utilise souvent et
que je trouve inapproprié en ascension
sociale new wave dont on parle tout d'un
escalier le jeune qui arrive chez nous
il va faire des efforts montée des
marches nous on est la rampe qui va
l'aider à monter les différentes étapes
quelquefois il va la marche sera haute
on pourra lui prêter notre époque mais
c'est lui de faire l'effort
de se former d'être assidus dans ces
stages en entreprise de réviser ces
partielles pour son bts de réviser ses
cours de bachoter quand il vient chez
nous en cours du soir mais c'est sa
volonté qui est la clé de sa réussite et
nous on le réveille au départ qui
veulent une volonté ont créé les
conditions pour qu'ils se rendent compte
qu'il a les capacités soit on lui a dit
alan par l'éducation nationale on a
souvent on lui a souvent dit ou sous en
fait comprendre ce qui est pire qu'il
n'avait pas les capacités pour réussir
chez nous on va lui expliquer qu'il a
les capacités pour réussir et qu'on va
l'accompagner à cette réussite c'est la
philosophie justement quel est votre
public cible à la base alors suivant
dispositif à des publics cibles
différents les écoles deuxième chance et
les jeunes entre 16 et 25 ans qui sont
ni diplôme et d'y former ses des fameux
décrocheurs long en fin de compte ce qu
ont arrêté leur cursus lycéen en bac
ou juste après qu'ils ont longtemps a
pas été formé
qui sont ces jeunes qui sont restés trop
longtemps dans un canapé en train
attendre classe parce qu'ils nous sont
envoyées par les missions locales et par
le réseau villes comme caen chanteloup
vous avez un réseau d'acteurs on parlait
alors des clubs de sports les clubs de
sport sont les très bons prescripteurs
de jeunes puisque les entraîneurs ils
connaissent bien les jeunes ils savent
qui est plus scolarisée qui pourrait
réussir ensemble on s'emploie pas assez
hachey ce réseau là
dedans entraîneur de sport qui
connaissent bien ces jeunes dans l'est
dans les quartiers et on vous en envoie
aussi
l'avis de chanteloup jeu à tout le monde
je pense que catherine un mot à titre
personnel nous envoie des gens des gens
déjeunent tous les jours
en doute pas 30 secondes donc voilà pour
les écoles la même chance pour les
jeunes hans martin r c'est donc en qui a
lieu en ce pont supérieur c'est déjà une
grande bac ou le niveau bac qui n'ont
pas réussi à s'inscrire dans un bts ou à
faire une formation
universitaire qui veulent reprendre des
études enfin les parfois des gens qui a
été écarté par le père cour suprême a
réussi à avoir leurs voeux parcours sub
ssa c'est une partie importante de
jeunes aussi et qui viennent s'inscrire
chez nous ils deviennent étudiants ils
vont s'inscrire à un bts ils vont passer
leurs examens ils vont passer leur bac
aussi via le 10e
et vont reprendre ainsi que dans
seulement supérieur à chanteloup donc on
a créé une université à chanteloup un
champ tout une ville universitaire
et on aura tout à l'heure d'été bonnaire
de
suivi cea ça voulait qui parle le mieux
grigol de nos jeunes nos formateurs mais
ça veut dire quoi on a les meilleurs
cours universitaires et ils sont avec
nous en fin de compte ils ont ils vont
s'inscrire en bts via le cned
one formation à distance via le cned
comme tout un chacun et nous la
particularité si nous allons voir un
coach qui va l'accompagner tout au long
de sa scolarité ce soit et des
saignements individualisé vous à fait ok
il va l'accompagner pour voir si il a
bien rendu c'est de voir s'il ya des
difficultés à comprendre il voit aussi
l'accompagner pour qu'il ait sa bourse
aux crous qui les étudiants pour qu'il
est peut-être une aide avec la mission
locale tous les freins ce qui peut avoir
dans son parcours d'étudiant on va
l'aider à les lever avec lui et on va le
motiver le suivre vérifier que ça
réussit ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui dans
les étudiants du cned on a de meilleures
réussites dans le nez sparte université
du hub que au cned en moyenne sachant
que le cnete vous avez comme une grande
partie qui sont des expats qui vivent à
nouveau un niveau socioculturel sans
doute un peu plus élevé que nos jeunes
de nos quartiers - accompagner mais ils
sont moins accompagnés - coach et donc
c'est vraiment le travail du coach et
des coach et ça se félicite parce qu'ils
lâchent pas la faire comme on dit et ils
passent un temps de dingue pour les
faire réussir c'est l'objectif rien sur
as ça coûte cher ça non ça coûte cher
oui
on est financée je pense que vous voyez
pas la télé mais à catherine bouquet
dans mon angle donc quand je dis coûte
cher la peur que je demande si l'ancien
département au département pas la ville
je te promets
alors le laas partenaires cités est
labellisé campus connectés donc elle est
financée par l'état sur un appel à
projets et puis financement aussi
d'autres collectivités il ya la mise à
disposition des locaux par par la ville
de chanteloup et sur l'école deuxième
chance c'est l'état la région et les
collectivités qui abondent le budget
mais comme tout à l'heure vous disiez
c'est la volonté des élus locaux de
porter ces projets là sur leur
territoire et de pousser pour que
l'ensemble des collectivités puissent
financer ces projets là c'est vraiment
ce que vraiment
on a des indices partenaires cités on en
a dans 93 on a un peu partout en ile de
france c'est souvent des mères qui
viennent on cherche en temps je veux et
on va se débrouiller au départ on part
avec une feuille blanche on sait pas si
on aura l'argent pour ouvrir ou pas mais
les maires se débrouille d'aller trouver
les appels à projets les subventions etc
c'est vraiment cette volonté de faire
réussir sa jeunesse qui est le moteur
enfin compte des ouvertures des
spartiates et des lobes la réussite est
donc et sur le territoire les l'eop de
la réussite c'est depuis 2010 9 je crois
est d'accord c'est le premier qu'on ait
ouvert en ile de france d'accord j'ai
une certaine pression pour pour l'ouvrir
en premier si j'étais la personne qui
m'a mis la pression
qu'ils aient un local alors un
une histoire de local j'ai trouvé des
failles trouver des locaux il fallait
aménager il faut être libre les livres
mouillés et ça a été très très
rapidement je pense qu'en moins de six
mois on a ouvert un dispositif
aujourd'hui on accueille 90 gilles
jeunes en écho d une chance par an ici à
chanteloup
près de sept sur dix ont une sortie
possible circuit soit il trouve un
emploi une formation ce qui est une
belle réussite
sur les sur les bts alors je je je crois
que sur les bacs on est à près de 100%
de réussite sur les bts on être à 7 sur
10 d'obtention du bétey ski je regarde
ma solde de la spartine c'était qu'il
contrechamp là bas mais qui me vous avez
des
people alors je sais pas si je suis
entouré ou en cercle et je pense que je
suis entouré et nous faisait tenir
autour et voilà je suis bien entouré
mais bien parce que parce que en fait
contre la réussite de ces jeunes là
parce que il ya des professionnels qui
chaque jour
dépense une énergie
considérable mais parce que si vous avez
cette émission là on est tous fascinés
un peu laissé aller chez dévouement de
tous ces gens qui travaillent parce que
alors en compte alors vous parlez des
locaux c'est nous et nous était un
pourquoi important pour nous on en a
beaucoup parlé catherine que le coup ils
ressemblent pas
à ce qu'on pouvait entendre de locaux de
centres de formation ou de maisons de
quartier comme on pourrait faire des
années 90 c'est à dire un truc un peu
d'humour nous nous efforçons colorés
sont pratiques on pourrait en rire quand
on rentre on pense plutôt à un tiers
lieu
de deux start-up ou de houe de
d'incubateur d'entreprises parce que
c'est important aussi que dans la
démarche d'insertion on les respecte
aussi par locaux que les locaux puissent
aussi respirer la réussite pour pas que
ce soit du low cost on est en train de
mettre en place ces cours du soir entre
entre 18h et 20h on a fait plus de 800
heures de cours du soir depuis novembre
avec les lycéens de chanteloup ça va les
accompagner sur leurs devoirs un peu de
méthodologie c'est 36 lycéens qu'on a on
accompagne ces petits projets là qui
font qu'un territoire réussit enfin
compte si c'est pas les gros projets qui
viennent d'en haut qui tombe c'est des
projets qui sont qui sont faits en
construction avec les acteurs du
territoire c'est ça qui est intéressant
et qui répondent complètement besoins du
territoire c'est ça qui c'est ça qui est
bien qu'ils émanent en fait et on avec
l'impulsion de catherine arenou on
travaille de façon vraiment privilégié
avec les acteurs locaux on a aussi des
des experts on va dire des associations
et cabinet qui viennent extérieur mais
la première volonté c'est de travailler
avec les acteurs locaux qui ont une
vraie compétence un vrai savoir faire et
un contact direct avec la population ce
qui est important c'est donc jeudi
étaient là ont fait l'insertion
économique sévère que on n'est pas fair
insertion sociale en f1 c'est un comique
ça veut dire quoi sire que tous les
parcours qu'on fait pour nos jeunes
la finalité c'est l'emploi c'est le
placer l'emploi parce qu'on pense que la
l'épanouissement et la réussite
personnelle elle passe par pouvoir avoir
un emploi on est aussi un acteur
développement économique le quand vous
arrivez à former sur internet sur un
bassin d'emploi quoi soit bassin de vie
aussi un bassin d'emploi que les jeunes
qu'on accompagne si on puisse les mettre
en stage dans les entreprises du
territoire complices et des entreprises
et aura recruté sur le sur le territoire
on contribue aussi à la création
richesse humaine mais aussi économiques
c'est important d'avoir cette finalité
là
l'occupation c'est de la réussite c'est
ce que vous exprimez d'ailleurs dans
lors de l'inauguration dans ce que vous
parlez de vous disiez que le hub de la
réussite c'est une solution offerte à
chaque jeune c'est cette idée que vous
vouliez véhicule est justement que vous
leur proposer quelque chose du début
jusqu'à la fin et à la sortie ils ont
ils ont quelque chose alors vous parliez
de 7 jeunes sur dix alors lé 3 restants
et trois qu'on en fait alors les 3
restants vous c'est assez c'est assez
varié
les fonctionnements des économies chance
c'est comme une entreprise ou à une
période d'essai vous avez un stage
obligatoire et après vous êtes en
alternance il ya des jeunes qui ont
parfois sont pas encore prêts à avoir ce
rythme là ce cycle là et donc l d'échec
et donc oui cet échec de 3 sur 10 qui
est diverse et variée il ya des jeunes
qui après la période d'essai c'est nous
qui mettait enfin parce qu'on considère
qu'ils ont pas encore la maternité de
projet ou où les retire les clés de la
réussite
une part de leur volonté il faut qu'il
monte les s'ils veulent pas on peut pas
le faire avant et donc oui il ya une
partie qui ne réussit pas comme comme
tout comme quand vous avez un employé
des fois mais tu es fameux père décès
mais ce que voulaient diriger vers
d'autres structures oui on verra lors
battre avec les missions locales avec
les opérateurs du territoire pour
parfois les maîtres pendant le disent
ils ont besoin d'avoir d'être sorti
sortie du territoire mais s'ils ont
besoin de bouger il y en a qui vont
partir sur ce qu'ils trouvent pas leur
voile à repartir sur d'autres formations
mais on va pas or un parcours avec eux
parce que c'est qu'elle sait des jeunes
qu'on va prendre qui vont être pendant
huit mois chez nous à 35 heures ont
commencé à 8h30 le matin
ça peut un peu vous lars eller quotidien
qu'ils avaient jusqu'à présent voilà
donc il faut quand même une certaine
maturité leur parcours pour qui ce
pouvoir
subir j'allais dire ce parcours là pour
compléter un vrai réseau jeunesse sur le
territoire avec un bureau information
jeunesse
le effectivement pôle emploi mission
locale mais aussi air peu à eux que
rencontrent pour l'égalité d'accès à
l'emploi c'est à dire qu'il ya une
multitude de
dispositifs possibles qui peuvent encore
relancé le projet du jeune ouais il ya
aussi les coachs de développement par le
sport voilà il ya coach sportif il ya
beaucoup de choses
vraiment un jeune à chanteloup peut être
soutenu si voilà j'ai envie de dire
il faut le vouloir voulez vous le voir
là la cité et de simone règle elle sera
sera ouverte qu'en ya un délai nord
alors oui adel il est prévu il est
probable que l ouïe prévue à la rentrée
à la rentrée 2000 24,2 millions de
cobayes avec avec toute cette difficulté
de travailler tellement en amont avec
des enfants les parents que on n'est pas
dans la même temporalité et que les
habitants donc on était très on est sur
le fil 1 en fait mais on travaille quand
même avec les habitants à savoir que
quand on a commencé
qu'on se concerter avec des enfants en
2024 et seront même plus scolarisés dans
l'équipement et dans les écoles sont les
avec lesquels on a travaillé voilà mais
c'est ça c'est ça la politique de la
ville et ce à tous les projets de
rénovation urbaine ça prend du temps il
faut on est vraiment en fait de l'ordre
dans la dent de la dentelle et la
communication c'est important et
l'émission et je vois que j'ai roulé je
vois que l'école sur laquelle ça doit
être construit il est toujours là donc
oui il est prévu entre 8 femmes de
encore des enfants même de dieu non j'ai
pas dit que twitter
on attend que les prix soient sound
année vous voyez c'est quand même pas si
lointain donc à l'automne 2022 ok là on
va poursuivre un peu cette conversation
justement avec des jeunes qui ont
bénéficié soit de la partie diversité
soit l'école de la deuxième chance et
puis et puis après on parlera aussi de
formation et d'insertion quelqu'un
d'aussi est évidemment essentiel merci
beaucoup que
je vous propose tout de suite quelques
témoignages de jeunes qui sont passés
par l'école de la deuxième chance
on va enregistrer ce dont on vient de
parler avec benjamin ce trône avec avec
trois à trois chaînes qui sont la
formidable vous aller témoigner vous
allez de raconter votre parcours
bas à commencer par vous
vous êtes
sarrasine c'est ça et vous êtes vous
avez fait l'école de la deuxième chance
à chanteloup oui et ça vous a permis de
trouver un emploi que si je crois que
vous êtes à la mission locale
intercommunale pas si conflent
en fait grâce à l'école de la deuxième
chance j'ai eu l'opportunité de faire un
stage de deux mois à la mission locale
intercommunale aussi conflent et après
ce stage j'ai signé un contrat cdd un
nom et ont même temps j'ai préparé mon
diplôme c'est un vrai pour
pour un poste d'agent d'accueil agents
administratifs
et
moi j'ai fait un an j'ai travaillé un an
à la mission locale donc c'était bien
s'est bien passé ils m'ont dit même
qu'ils vont renouveler mon contrat donc
je suis très content donc voilà comment
vous êtes arrivé comment vous êtes
arrivé là comment vous êtes arrivé
oh oui
oui absolument comment vous êtes arrivé
dans cette école de la deuxième chance
en fait j'ai été orienté par la mission
locale parce que j'étais inscrits à la
mission locale et il ma conseillère
madame hélène à papa il m'a orientée à
l'école de la deuxième chance mais vous
étiez vous étiez au lycée avant vous
étiez non pas du tout certain temps que
je vous avais un jour donné les codes
arrêté l'école m'a dit tout en fait moi
je viens de l'italie
j'avais un diplôme d'opticien j'ai
cherché dans l'optique siens mais j'ai
pas trouvé
donc voila et j'ai vraiment avec le col
de la deuxième chose grâce à ça j'ai eu
l'opportunité de changer vraiment de
projet et je ne savais pas qui c'était
la première fois que je travaille dans
l'administratif donc c'est bien passé
d'accord ah oui vous des d'italie donc
d'être arrivé que toi tu peux faire
l'interview en
italien
[Rires]
c'est formidable et donc vous est
adressée la mission locale c'est comme
ça et qu'est ce qu'on apprend à l'école
c'est quoi le deuxième chance bah en
fait c'est un accompagnement renforcé
chacun est là vraiment accompagnants ont
forcé parce que - avant je savais pas
mais compétentes donc je savais même pas
qui ça peut m'intéresser l'administratif
donc si avec eux qui doucement ils vont
ils m'ont vraiment aidé mais pour le
français donc parce que je parlais pas
et voilà c'est vraiment pour m'aider
pour savoir mes compétences pour pour
vraiment le projet professionnel de le
chercher on a fait plusieurs tests pour
voir donc voilà et je pense c'est très
très bien très bien fait ça vous a mis
dans le seul chemin d'emploi déjà oui
c'est ça ouais c'est probable on parle
un peu avec adèle touré
alors vous êtes
étudiante en première année de bts alors
là ces négociations digitalisation
relation client ça
se comprend pas tout
servir
là vous vous avez bénéficié de la
spartine diversité un césar oui c'est ça
mais alors avant qu'il était votre
parcours et au lycée vous avez passé le
bac oui j'étais au lycée j'ai obtenu mon
bac en 2019 un bac pro vente et après
j'ai voulu chercher du travail donc j'ai
travaillé pendant une année et j'ai
voulu reprendre mes études mais
malheureusement j'ai pas trouvé et c'est
une année après que grâce à la mission
locale j'ai trouvé la smart universités
et que j'ai pu m'inscrire pour reprendre
mes études et c'était quoi les freins
quand vous avez voulu reprendre les
études qu'est-ce-qui qu'est-ce qui a
fait que vous n'avez pas trouvé là
j'étais pas déjà pris prioritaire sur
parcours sup donc forcément sur ça j'ai
pas mes voeux n'ont pas été acceptées
après j'ai sauté quoi vos voeux j'ai
essayé de en communication en assurant
son immobilier en tout ce qui concernait
mon bts un peu en mdr c'est en musique
et aucun des deux n'a été acceptée du
coup grâce à admission le cas j'ai pu
trouver cette formation est alors la
tienne 6 on en a un petit peu parlé avec
beaucoup problème avec ma maman je
connais deux parties de la cités mais
concrètement ça se passe comment
pour moi personnellement ça serait
plutôt bien ça me permet de travailler à
côté justement il cherchait vu ça veut
dire que vous si vous avez opté des
cours par correspondance et à ses à
distance mais on est dans des locaux on
a des ordinateurs on peut travailler à
distance
et vous êtes et iliad est d'aider des
gens des coachs enfin
avec nous qui nous aide qui nous fait
une fois par semaine nous voit et nous
fait un point pour savoir un peu ce
qu'on a fait ce qu'on n'a pas fait si on
a du mal à nous aide est toujours là
pour nous et si on a besoin d'elle on va
l'avoir et le monde discute avec elle
lui a dit qu on est à la fois on a les
cours de de diversité comme comme c'est
un studio et on est quand même et des
suivis par
c'est votre choix est elle toujours
disponible pour nous donc ça c'est super
on est à distance mais on a quand même
quelqu'un pour nous accompagner à tout
appel à qui est ce un dock est je pense
que
ça va mieux et vous disiez vous vous
travaillez votre avion c'est en
alternance et en contrat d'alternance
sénat en fait j'en sais un s'est dit que
j'ai eu à pau après mon bac 6 à trouver
un travail et fut là bas je suis devenue
formatrice d'ailleurs vingt deux recrues
là bas et ils ça me tenait vraiment à
coeur de trouver une formation dans
laquelle je pouvais également travailler
à côté et grâce à asma j'arrivais à
faire les deux oui justement j'arrive à
faire les deux je travaille le soir et
j'ai cours à la smart la journée et à
terme quelles sont vos perspectives pour
vos objectifs qu'est ce que vous voyez
faire là après
après cette formation mais j'espère déjà
obtenu mon bts et ensuite continuer mes
études dans une licence en marketing
oui oui donc ça vous a permis voilà de
reprendre des études de travailler 20
ans d'être suivi donc voilà c'est un
parcours formidable raphaël lips bonjour
alors
vous êtes deuxième année vous devez sa
de bts et commerce international
vous que vous étiez parti en australie
16 ans alors oui j'ai un parcours un peu
atypique parce que quand j'ai eu mon bac
j'ai voulu faire une formation normale
en licence est en fait sur parcours
subjectif mais mes premiers choix et jeu
mais j'étais dans une forme à ce degré
voulais faire c'était éco-gestion donc
voilà et ces dons c'est un peu loin
c'était
j'en ai lu c'était plus d'une heure
trente de transport allait 1h30 retour
et en plus c'était des cours magistraux
qui plaisait pas trop et du coup j'ai
décidé d'arrêter fin de quitter lavenac
et je me suis mis en idée de partir en
australie donc voilà j'ai connu une fin
j'ai que j'ai travaillé pendant une
année à peu près j'ai économisé de
l'argent et je suis parti une année
complète en en australie par exemple
trouve du boulot facilement en australie
alors à l'époque oui il ya dix ans
c'était très facile maintenant il y
avait quand même beaucoup de gens comme
moi qui tentent leur chance en australie
il ya du travail mais souvent c'est du
travail et un peu de jus etc mais oui on
peut trier guava bas j'ai fait plein de
fans boulot ggg fait la plonge et fait
du service j'ai travaillé dans des dans
les champs la distribution prospectus
donc ouais j'ai fait plein de trucs
différents voilà et quand vous revenez
évidemment difficile de s'inscrire
quelques pas bah oui parce que déjà
le système français après deux ans sans
travail et inuh concert comme
déscolarisés et trouver une école qu'on
est déscolarisé c'est pas top 1 c'est
plus facile quoi et surtout que j'étais
pas j'étais revenu trop tarder australie
j'étais revenu en juin et que toutes les
procédures de parcours super tweet est
déjà finie et que depuis l'australie
c'était dur pour moi de postuler de
faire les toutes les les entre tous les
entretiens et hop aux écoles et du coup
bah j'ai pas pu inscrire un école voilà
d'où la smart et immersive à la saison
donc celle à la mission locale de mantes
la jolie à côté de là où j'habite et ils
ont redirigé vers la mi enfin la smart
universités
donc voilà prêt juin un entretien on a
vu ensemble ce qu'on pouvait faire et
j'ai été accepté et aujourd'hui vous en
est où là du coup donc là du coup 102e
année j'ai réussi à passer ma première
année
ici tout s'est bien passé
on a en fait on est bien encadrée comme
des lieux a précisé on a une coach qui
évacue sur notre avancement et tout on a
aussi de temps en temps des intervenants
qui viennent on a notamment approuvé
d'anglais michel qui vient tous les
mercredis bénévolement et on avait aussi
un prof de maths qui est venu plusieurs
fois et donc en fait voilà on est on est
bien accompagné on avance à notre rythme
vu que c'est les cours en ligne
quand on est en cours magistral souvent
il ya un truc qu'on n'a pas bien compris
et on est déjà passé à autre chose il
dit les voilà leur classe ils quelque
chose qu'on a du mal à comprendre de
prendre notre temps pour bien travailler
dessus et comme ça on est sûr d'avoir
bien tout compris et voilà donc j'ai
passé un premières années maintenant je
chantais à mener alors vous êtes assez
courageux parce que vous avez fait cette
deuxième année de bts vous travaillez en
même temps oui c'est ça la semaine et le
week-end c'est donc la semaine deux fois
par semaine jeudi le mardi je suis
tuteur dans le projet de soutien
scolaire justement dont vous aviez parlé
je crois
comme j'ai vécu en australie jamais
voilà en anglais donc je peux me
permettre d'aider des lycéens en anglais
même sur la méthodologie vu que j'ai eu
un bac es sur l'économie l'histoire etc
et il voit là ça se passe super bien et
et le week-end de jus jardinier j'ai
pris mon expérience on ne le traduit un
prêt en australie va j'ai appris avant
en france je travaillais pour le club de
paris en mai c'est extraordinaire parce
que c'est héroïque d'ailleurs je pense
qu'on devrait à la fin du cursus
classique on voyait les jeunes à
l'étranger
déjà ça ouvre sur le monde c'est celui
où alors souvenir des italiens
oui mais après il faut les former
c'est bien vous êtes heureux d'avoir
trouvé au fond ce cursus
vous permet de trouver un emploi vous
permis de reprendre des études
c'est quand même une seconde mais c'est
sûr parce que
0,2 de deux potes de copines de copains
qui ont les à pau les doubles cursus que
vous
ben moi personnellement j'ai des amis
qui sont en pro en classe
professionnelle j'ai votre ami qui a un
master qui vient de finir là et donc
ouais tout le met plus ou moins peu des
parcours différents donc
oui c'est
la même la plupart de mes amis ont
réussi à trouver des formations dans des
écoles et actuellement ils travaillent
et font leur formation aussi d'accord
d'accord moi non j'ai pas des amis qui
est vraiment aux en fait moi je les
pousse un petit peu quand même donc je
le dis il faut faire il faut il faut
aller à l'école et il faut travailler il
faut pas rester à la maison donc quand
ils me voient un petit peu il regarde
que j'ai fait quand même je viens
d'arriver j'ai fait un parcours je suis
en contrat et je travaille donc un petit
peu de pouce pour lui dire voilà il faut
comme lui il faut dire que voilà c'est
très bien c'est est ce que vous avez
fait mais vous avez voulu aussi le faire
faut vouloir bosser un faut bosser un
moment et c'est sa façon il n'y a pas de
secret on sait s'il n'ya pas la volonté
de la personne elle même personne peut
rien faire pour elle a
en tout cas bravo et merci de vos
témoignages west était intéressant
d'avoir voilà comment ça se passait
concrètement merci merci beaucoup à tous
les trois merci puis plein de réussite
pour vos projets
[Musique]